okay so let's carry on because it's been
a little while I actually can't even
remember where we got to it's been it's
been that long
[Music]
where are we
and then we were seeing like little dead
things by the way let me know if the
audio needs kind of like haggling if you
want me to up the game audio or up my
audio for handling the big bad wolf if
the roof runs at you ready to attack
then you should not have any regrets
about new life because you almost
probably die it says save sterols for
handling the big bad wolf if bill runs
out you ready to attack and you shall
not have any regrets about your life
because you will most probably die who
so if I don't have regrets
they won't will let me put it yeah yeah
that's totally what it means and now I'm
alright Jack Jack I don't really fancy
going out you know on half the party all
the time
maybe we can find a clue in the computer
yeah but it needs that password I'll
find it wait okay so I need a password
to do this and we don't know it yet so I
guess we'll find out we need to find a
key look around all right well there's a
safe there there's also oh okay and they
still say that bucket shoes look inside
but you know these boots are made for
walking and that's just what they'll do
Miss Fortune one of my leaders
[Music]
Oh in the code Oh why would it be in
baby look from the paper would some
numbers okay the past might be helpful
eight nine four five should we go
might as well just go there now Oh
unless it's the safe you wanted them I
think that's right here there's no
computer skills
the password is this one eight ninety
four five I think you're holding the
paper upside down
well then don't interrupt me I know what
I'm doing keep quiet
hey Tasha Bates up in love with this
game sister came out I watched all the
walkthroughs and even bought the fancy
Edition even talking about it in this
assignment college just awesome I'm
guessing you played Fran Birds well then
yeah I loved front I love ya
Fran bow and this game is so great so
far but I just have to kill many games I
just think they're whole the way that
they're like developing games and being
so open with their community and it's
just cool it's just cool
I like them too eight nine four five
eight how do I am like say yes I want
this okay that cool
[Music]
maybe it's longer than what do you mean
it says six down the bottom always a six
as in that's not a nine that's a six
okay so maybe it's like eight six four
five now
how could it be that five four six Hey
oh yeah means for children Lina
tremendous is a computer scientist you
really surprised me private [ __ ] let's
see what it says are you there glad a
bladder bloat I was in the toilet well
wait wait wait I'm not there yet
stop how is that your impression was
fine and super we can talk about it some
other time take care
I forgot to tell you about there's a
spare key oh okay so this is how we get
the kids it's in the safe when you code
to seven five eight one two seven five
eight one how's the bear doing the bear
keeps sucking the popsicle this game is
so weird I love it
I'm not sure but I like to watch winky
face what okay we're gonna hear now what
kind of people are these right two seven
five eight one remember that guys in two
seven five eight one just in case I
don't two seven five eight one a secret
inside two seven five eight one five
eight one yes the best little in your
lady Thank You Becky sweet well done
Miss Fortune very impressive
let Jackson Jack part is a cool witness
your friends miss your housemates you
don't know the people I'm good thanks
though I appreciate you looking out for
me I have the key let's go and if we get
lucky I'll bet it this game is similar
to Feinberg well yeah in a sense so it
must say pretty without ribs you'll see
you'll take it I can reach it from here
see if you can't get inside and yeah
it's from the same makers a father with
the most dearest 8 boys
hmm I don't know anyone called Johnny
cuz that I'm talking about Benjamin he's
this sweet looking so for anyone that
didn't watch fast one she has this weird
crush on her Fox
Benjamin maybe you should stop talking
to him and find a way inside the cage
misfortune all right yeah guide dog text
so this game is quite disturbing as well
it might not be on this thing actually
no it some parts are on the same scale
as Fran bow it's it kind of just
randomly comes out of no way me when you
least expect it it says
also known as the big bad wolf his
favorite snack is Red Hood of little
girls that's silly
we never reuse children mm-hmm - behind
it is eating the children who knows
you're right we should call the cops ooh
yeah
we don't want to get involved with the
police I just remembered everything that
happened before we don't we don't trust
this narrator dude because he was trying
to make us kill Benjamin right and then
I didn't and then he was saying how
annoying she is yeah no we don't we
don't trust mrs. Vega
oh my god you a nice person
what's gonna heal away why can't the
little lady just hurt the wolf oh that
was unexpected he must usually run away
from me that's too bad but hey the note
is right there why is that on the red
string it looks so inconspicuous my evil
cousins dress out so good now we can get
that stolen happiness back great sleep
it looks like the fastest way to the Fox
is by boat from phantasmagoria you tell
me we are going to phantasmagoria it
seems that way yes are you up for
another round of missing kids great
great but as usual just be honest
so love oh yeah be honest question ever
heard this question before
[Music]
no I have not heard that question before
alright second question have you ever
lied to a friend well yeah like you know
when that birthday party is coming up
and I don't know what is I'm in school
sherilyn while I don't believe my body
clothes and pick me up after school is
well beyond the trees oh well she's not
watching if you say so now for the last
question have you ever seen someone you
die
[Music]
well she was I mean he was already dead
but she threw a dead person does that
I'm guessing is a yes from her for me it
was very cool in the movies it was
different me as it goes but he hasn't
done it yet thank you for your honesty
again miss fortunately we're getting
really close to phantasmagoria
[Music]
this is like a cross between the Stanley
parable oh yeah I guess because of the
narrator rule cool happy Hilary god this
looks like the creepiest please deliver
it to right though I wish with America's
presence well it's not falling just in
front of you I take it please don't play
with my feelings it can't be a ticket
are you sure it looks like a ticket to
me it can't be but I'll check it out is
that a skeleton crap you're welcome
misfortunate now let's go find a boat to
the talks where this looks so cool
it says welcome to phantasmagoria oh
when you spooky clown wait I think I can
throw my room I am yes please Marco okay
misfortune cuz it made that noise what's
the sparkle button again I forgot it's
been so long
that's me it's like how she views the
world because she's so innocent sweet
hey you from the other side yes fortune
deserves to have a fun time so try to
make the right choices for her all right
what I have been well I made this entire
game don't judge me mr. Narita man
please have one ticket so I can just
write one right I'm gonna look around
first all right
whoa cool
you know once I saw the documentary on
TV about hot dogs I don't want to eat
hot dogs I think that's a good decision
I actually got put off sausages when I
was a kid
oh Jesus right sorry about that I was
just trying to pull your leg I'll just
shoot me I stink and be nothing
there's people massive spooky see I
agree but I've really liked the concept
of people just hiding behind a fake
exterior because that's what we actually
do right when we're walking around on
the street
[Music]
[Music]
okay so there's the carousel
pumpkin that means children at school
say that I have a pumpkin I see them I
was told I had a big forehead nothing
means II don't trust her firstly my
tongue is delightful ah yes too bad we
can't afford a first-time County on the
ground I could use the party huh to make
my own mix comical come on misfortune
don't even think about it oh really
gonna eat some of it
[Music]
shiri let her eat the candy I mean it's
company and Rapids right yeah okay why
no oh it's really delicious
Oh No thank you thing this prayer I'm
sorry
oh no I'm she's ill I just want to have
a good time Oh
oh she's brought back home with her mom
what he started
what is it misfortune I think they come
they make me feel bad well I told you
not to eat it yeah that's true
Healing me there you go she's been
enough she has she has enough Sparkle
Larry won't do that to you again
oh the horror house I think we should
let her go in the horror house I'm
pretty sure that's what I'm gonna choose
yeah that's one Ritchie's through the
carousel that's the boring we're going
into the horror suite it's this the ride
you want to spend your ticket on do we
agree guys do we agree I mean I really
want to go in him
trying to wait for the lag to catch up
but I know I want to choose this anyway
so I'm just going to choose it yeah all
right then it's probably important the
worst life decision because it's not the
safest one
now that is all animated there
[Music]
spooky havens like
it's gonna be sick
Oh No but then I went too fast it was
them all right good
take a deep way oh she enjoyed it she
can do it I was amazing okay good good
now let's go find okay let's go find the
book review starting that whoa it's a
ghost boys the missing boy right
ah there's benjin how with real briefly
one no of course you must play one
before we leave on the boat I just love
it here don't you oh that all about
Benjamin why I'm gonna be responsible
I'm not going to allow how to play with
real bullets okay maybe maybe whack a
fox or any other games Oh whoo there's a
fortune teller huh what's this
it's in the stone with a hound oh and a
ghost hello
[Music]
should we go to the fortune teller or
should we try and get stoned she'll
sleep through a golden okay so try and
get that off it is a Fortuna we can't
get a reward
it looks like you need a reward time
okay
mmm so we're gonna have a decision to
make after we get this I'm gonna do
wacky Fox check this out I can get the
reward ticket if I win I'm gonna play
this please go ahead
I can't wait to see what it's about it's
about whacking of all obviously Lou hi
this thing folks is like Benjamin
they're dangerous foxes pretend they all
stole your eternal happiness and watch
them watch them
yes
[Music]
seems to exclusively these two Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
here's my word right walking misfortune
yeah this thing again I want to get more
tickets
[Music]
Oh No anytime's
okay yeah
[Music]
[Music]
how many tickets three one I don't know
Allah or the coming to give them again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again on all the game
[Music]
I'm just gonna keep going cuz I know
there's a lot of stuff we can get with
these tickets oh damn it how many we got
now count five nice I'm gonna do one
wall I'm kind of addicted dancing
yeah
[Music]
well ma 31 I'm training for whenever I
play Milo Medin again okay right now
we'll stop
I mean eight tickets come on that's
pretty good we can get some stuff at the
head three hours late day so should we
do the for each other yeah young
I miss fortune Ramirez had a mammoth
then I want to know the future of me
thank you she has the same once you see
the beyond the beyond sees you and you
can be sure it will be coming for you
get me ill knees coming for me that was
such a waste of it again want to try
again shall we to try again no should we
leave it what do you think
now we'll leave it I'll use my tickets
for this
[Music]
[Music]
reality will transform into what the
child so what the sharpest tires the
most when I have one more ticket so we
might as well go back miss fortune
teller one last time I'm a [ __ ] Lily I
got all the rewards let's go back one
more time
she better not tell us a lot what you
see in the beyond is not what you see a
lot of waste but what you don't see want
to try it again
oh wait no no cuz I am a ticket that was
different but it is basically the same
so I'm going
[Music]
I wanna do some pumpkin carving it says
you need one golden coin minute right
there both huh
last year I did pumpkin carving on my
friend Tom hi Tom here watching probably
not and I made a salad figures pumpkin
it's like a Black Swan how cool is that
really really cool
anyway this bow will take you where you
need to go
you mean to Benjamin's house yes and
it's just one golden coin I got that
this sweet chocolate going the reward is
that good I do think that would oh look
at that
well are you ready to leave yeah I got
all the stuff
is going to be so cool I hope we don't
get our talk-line virus though oh the
Kraken what's that well if you see it
you know but Lillian curious is try
crack don't have time for that [ __ ] Rob
just good frog think about it forever
that's deaf you are correct
Kamala if you appear in front of me I
will see you and if I see you I will
know it is you see if I can come up in
front of me
[Music]
what's a freaking crackin hey this place
is that require I was thinking is the
Pritam available for petting you know
like I don't think you'd wanna be some
rockin she was emphatic like if it's
possible well I hadn't figured out with
fish with fishes for a while Betty
McGregor was that the fish from the
bridge yeah very happy because I save
him you remember I save him from the
bridge remember yes I remember did you
see that give him everything on my mouth
because he was in love with me lovely
save of him somebody loves me
q hey mysterious are you taking me now
to the house of Benjamin
that blue light soft fluffy folks who
happens to be a great artist and stole
my happiness you don't seem to want to
talk about it and the lion stuff to
collect coins that's how you pay for
your random food right misfortune he
won't still here anyway
do you like to eat socially I know about
sushi because I have a Japanese ghost
friend by the way
and you speak Japanese I need some
translations do you know what this is
you Peedee mother with Asuka seems like
it's building up to something so you
don't know huh you know I've never been
outside this light by myself do you go
outside buy or sell this place you're
gonna just sleep after rain I am going
to make my chocolate coins yeah oh stop
talking why should I stop talking nobody
else has spoken
hi mysterious where are you pulling can
you swim he's had a mouth that's what
happens
ladies ask too many questions
it makes people want to drown themselves
well not stupid I'm pretty sure he'll be
fine
look we on the right see then rare so
freaking me
the Frenchman split shakedown oh it's
deployed gravy oh I'm telling you
whatever you say misfortune it was like
quicksand to me playing with it it's
getting really dark mr. Boies are you
mad
hello there's something wrong here
something very wrong
What's Wrong mr. voice what do you mean
it's coming hide hi
I don't know what you're playing but if
you scare me I'll close my eyes
ah there he is a little ghost friend
[Music]
each skill
can be found stolen this is your family
from the woods
say hello and now say bye-bye mine is
only because we're leaving
that's cute I like that they got it that
good stuck
oh [ __ ]
look you the chat they can slow down
running away from do you don't see the
money sure was the Fox there's the Fox
don't make any sudden moves
should I cap yeah I trust Benjamin I'm
gonna get up don't touch her would your
filthy paws you beasts stupid you're
just getting him away
[Music]
see I like Benjamin he's nice he's
watching stop and listen to me there's
something I need to tell you if you keep
running you end up badly hurt and I
don't want that you're too important but
I want the same thing young man he was
nice to me trust me he's dangerous
stop running please
what should we do I feel like we should
keep running but at the same time I do
you feel like you know she did get her
little foot trapped so maybe he had the
point I'm gonna let you guys decide this
one
just waiting for the leg to catch up I
don't know I feel like if it was me I
would choose to keep running after
Benjamin but just because I don't trust
mr. Boies but I'll see what you guys
think tomorrow you want to listen iced
out Rustom
I mean everyone else is saying to keep
running I'm gonna go with the majority
vote I'm gonna just wait a little bit
longer to see what other people think
we've got three four keep running and
one for listen oh my gosh we got way
more to keep running now so I'm gonna
keep running I'm sorry kumara I think I
think you'd like seen this already right
I think you you know something we don't
know but I'm just gonna stick with my
gut and everyone else's guts and we're
gonna keep running Oh sighs I don't
remember me saying if you keep running
you end up hurt did you I could have
been more specific like there's a bad
truck up ahead stop or you will be hurt
but I felt like getting straight to the
point
okay thank you you put the left up there
to up here anyway
I haven't seen any bears well I don't
want to point any fingers but it was
obviously the Fox awesome it was the
voice like the Fox I have what you call
Fox of Tobia is that Oxley I swear no
let's focus on the eternal happiness
again all right
[ __ ] the baby oh this makes me think
about pop see you know dick did I showed
you about to see the hoodie in the
secret spot yeah there is that to know
about this you know this benefit because
he's a penny there and I've seen I
handle fantasy where there are no better
crops for Kenneth he'll go in the woods
he will see this and look know his diam
who is if I had been killed by a Bertram
that's how it is now he's dead but they
died
what are you talking about come on pop
see don't you listen let's keep going
now he's fortunate I agree with you mind
sighs I think so Boyce is the antagonist
as well but we shall see
oh wait what's this these one looks like
the other one that they don't look like
the other ones you think yes so you'll
know yes
it's stuck huh the elimination of
priming will this load is still
interesting it's stuck
huh okay I can't take it back out so
that's the last one Oh what's this the
games you enjoy you can have them all oh
yes please give me on forget are you
doing so misfortune I have a couple of
questions for you are you ready you're
ready
wonderful now just be honest does that
the no tinnitus cure posturing first
question do you believe in magic
yeah of course freakin does I don't well
mummy and daddy scream I go to my secret
hiding spot Danny my secret but they
never drink Hugh delivers dream of me
that's magic open you pink oh yes yes it
is my sweet child
moving on second question do you trust
me No
yeah I guess that way seemingly have no
let me talks to herself I look - she
says she never demos and that they just
keep them away
I'm sorry did you hear that hi are you
believe innothing mom me a demon Wow no
you can't be a demon
not with that silly voice the juice
isn't bad the juices wine closed another
classic question are you afraid of dying
[Music]
yes I am I don't know if I will aim
she's gonna die today
what is like ken's bring me glitter well
I guess you'll find out when you die
looks like there's going to be a storm I
hope it doesn't rain that much I don't
like my fifth getting wet come on little
lady in your mouth
well hey she's found a guy thought up I
think we're here Thank You Lee
stay cool misfortune Burcu I've keep an
eye out here until you go inside and
look for clues
I'm sure that foxes in the eternal
happiness here I don't make sure that
cabin is every 12 yeah then you see the
Fox run all right
hey Tom was talking about you just now I
was talking about the pumpkins that we
made together
it looks like Benjamin's good at cutting
wood he must be some up you want a man
love those muscular [ __ ] sir okay I want
look go wrong we may I don't find me out
there not happiness if Benjamin - I
asked him to share that fries with us
and everything will be fine
yeah
is dis bangin you got some sweet style I
like it
she doesn't have a reflection she's a
vampire well I'll leave your player
booth oh yes so fancy is there ready on
let's see
making that will TPO there's a monster
I bet the monster is after Benjamin so
that's why Benjamin's doing got that
weird like ritual stuff to try and get
rid of the monster oh what a girl see
girls Oh what should we do guys should
we respect Benjamin's privacy I feel
like we should
I like super strong guys know I like
super strong foxes God why don't you
guys listen to me read the journal and
drink Benji's tea who's Benjy what what
are we talking about
if mr. voices in her head could she be
the antagonist that it's a very good
point from Bing Magnus and I what I
don't know you guys want me to read it
I'm in a bit concerned with her feelings
to her Fox ah she's a little girl you
know she won me eight she doesn't know
she try Rita there I feel bad
feel guilty you guys want me to read it
I don't wanna I don't wanna harm
Benjamin's trust only I'm gonna trust
her Lucas has respect
Nana mutt says name
it has backstory if you read in
all right more of you saying read it so
I'm blaming you if this backfires okay
inside my Benjamin you have malleus
breath folks do you knew his name was
Benjamin yeah how'd you know Belgium is
not from open films I bet he has an
accent I love that in a book I must make
dangerous danger dangerous mission fishy
must be done it's what I trying to make
nervous but it is ok I have study and
bigger confidence I travel from Center
City to Pandora where fog appears I pack
things and food no information on how
long stay over in cabin until work done
my tasks important Faust told me many
victims in town to the victims of the
little kids are going missing and
encouraged
Myron's thank you sir after long walk in
fog arrived city called open fields tiny
town is good forest tavern very nice as
TV a the cabin where and now kitchen I
see pasta a decorate cabin fish balls
smell funny ate mushrooms in words i
refresh after sleep try to find Paris I
did not find it
day one failed
there's kids and the hand the hand that
was gonna get us earlier many victims
got missing in Paris I came I can't help
feel sad I send message to boss some
victims not coming to send nur city I
see parasite it scared me
ok so the monster mister parasite also
not eating much more mushroom
stomachache him watch casts it's not
good don't eat this mushroom again the
victims eat mushrooms any mom mushrooms
serious danger not feel good danger
mushroom I stay home covered duty and
root soup good taste
I do dolls for victim of pitches if she
sees them good that's me well no my
sporty talk about because we've been
picking up the dolls first I recognized
Margo code po1 0 1 2 2 2 do we need to
know this o 1 o 1 2 2 2 remember that
just in case I like to play I has died
two steps courage tomorrow now rest
until summer good
feeling no stomachaches only gas I go
help missing victims in town Mon Morgan
oh im here morr go play old trick many
times our so the demons called more go
or the monster to harass like whatever
more go but it takes but it make mistake
one victim can hear it's voice inside
your head
guys we're right the antagonist
[Music]
is more go the voice in my head is more
go which is the monster it's more go
victim code misfortune is nice code more
go can't have her say boss
she must be rescued but I follow steps I
saw more go tape shape stair scary it's
a loser
yeah and you're the kid boss send me
message watch victim house
I see beside house hide in trash I fail
find parasite it did not come today big
trouble misfortune watch me strange
why'd she see me she has big eyes I run
away felt warm and stomach maybe
mushrooms tickle again he liked it I
seem ogre play Ocho kam victim don't
realize all is again all it is again
must courage and stop parasite this time
I send many victims to Center City
I got level 2 protector I counted it
okay so he's way
so the victims
aren't actually missing they've been
sent to this other land by Benjamin
now I has Prime Eve illumination cane ah
we did see him with the earlier shakeout
finger stick I try find me ballooning in
the elimination game and what's fun I
feel courage practicing to help Miss
Fortune I see she makes much talk I
think she fun and strong more go
confused by charms at the spot you I did
video picking word in Paris I came but
on courage now I scared only little yeah
do you know how to talk he loves me he
does I mrs. fourth I'm doing it today
all steps followed prepared breakfast
tea funny filling with tea perhaps from
words of fun I'm courage and confidence
today I ready has a boss he has a young
then I can be married to him yeah okay
that's some Bikeworks okay so I'm gonna
fix this
[Music]
okay no that doesn't weigh
it looks like Binyamin likes to educate
himself I like very much
look at the fun stories of a boring man
the meaning of love that's you when the
hatred wants to be loved communication
in cooperation learning how to be gray
[Music]
that's a team wait you said that the
TV's Maharis chorus right my man can I
have one of her little tricks again
alone because I can almost Milius balls
blown into inger idioms maybe I shall
try get out yes you're a liar have a
little weird trip it definitely tastes
like his fluffy balls mmm delicious
she's done so many drugs right okay yeah
weird
[Music]
it's a love sandwich oh wait this
functions already smelling attempts to
flee flies
peanutbutter mmm I love pinis lemon know
she was sick again yeah
serious look at that
Hammond look stuff ready and that half
there is Benjamin and as much broke your
video player but used only eternal
happiness it was promised to me if I
beat the game I really want it back
I can totally share it if you want are
you feeling why is he just running all
right what are you is this a piss is
this really happening what is that your
diary I'm sorry if you're upset because
I read it but I was curious isn't the
master in your diary you're afraid of I
think I saw him too
oh I think he would have just asked us
to Rita anyway
[Music]
mom following a Benjamin but you
rescuing me Benjamin
like if I was a girl in trouble
am i doing it
Benjamin why do you go there's the whole
behind the painting hello
I can't reach it
come on little animal well let's get the
first door then my life this is little I
have to do climb on things we just have
a little shave you know I'm to use my
ninja skills
hey I'm Muay Thai oh she's so relatable
their energy so this game is about
misfortune it's the following game from
front oh it's cute but oddly creepy and
really funny so it was fun get me
blazing days but bünyamin seems so nice
maybe he put them for the monster I mean
yeah hmm kind of fish sushi balls
hmm it's look there's a big picture of
the key hmm a picture of lucky
interesting my meager senses are telling
me to climb up on this chair I am
knowing ninja son says open real mean
dear lady always touches everything a
secret Babu
yes Helia all right then
I pushed the bottom I mean I don't think
that was other way to progress in the
game to be honest
it was easy time to play - okay
misfortunes much less - they're just
really good at building up our character
so choose you say unique but also very
relatable come on get up
you look stronger than you think it's
like this little moment here you'll be
knocked down before you can do
did you let that stop you
pan up misfortune you can do it yes you
be your own mana Lucas
because you're a strong independent lady
you are the little mm is fortune come on
yeah okay
[Music]
Bungie mr. voules want to go to the
woods now maybe no no been layin scary
doc can I pet it
I'll baby their soul sleep dream come
true but in the baby there
is that Benjamin's bug bünyamin are you
around he must be in trouble
I'm very disciplined have you seen
Benjamin they think he's in trouble
didn't you hear what I just said I'm
very disappointed in you mr. Boies
please stop playing games you have light
show me all that's right and that's very
sucky
I knew I couldn't trust you what are you
talking about I read with Benjamin wrote
in his diary all of it you're no one
taking the children and I I'm not the
hero of this game right
I guess the eternal happiness what's all
a lie stop this nonsense we have to keep
playing my game you can't make me yes I
can
it's not that then play with me you need
to find your eternal happiness I'll give
you a clue it's at home waiting for you
don't think of that eternal happiness
I don't woman anymore you can't say that
that would break the rules you harm me I
know one day eternal happiness anymore I
won't tolerate this behavior I will be
waiting for you at home yeah you ever
when he told her to leave her what do
you do to him
pretty monster hmm
let's see what's inside maybe a clue or
to find Benjamin
in that venue - our baby at the end of
the road you'll realize you already sign
the deal at the end of the road you will
realize you already signed the deal
obviously
oh this is really mysterious the
students the university of cemre saddest
technology so this is where he came from
protector course ah step three guide
three step guide was that through yard
through some bad men to exterminate
parasitic beings of the beyond as the
ultra-reality forms in hand at the
concept of time new realms are further
constituted FR in e
have appeared after the altar war
thousands of beings were discovered as
byproducts of the war they created for
themselves a new realm we refer to it as
the beyond the beyond is in simple terms
a place of extreme absurdity with no
logical laws of physics we can't allows
beings inside the FR e e at the moment
since the foundation of our reality is
based on the energetic and ethical
values of the ultra-reality before the
ultra war the beyond is still a
misunderstood ground we haven't yet
found the pieces to connect with it in a
logical manner
but three patterns we recognize are the
behaviour of some visitors also known as
parasites then normally enter the third
reality aka Pandora and seek fresh meat
slaw into the be honest and that's why
we need the protectors the protectors
are the only ones with the capability of
seeing the imbalance between realities
and using the tools available inside the
ultra-reality protectors will help
victims and guide them into sin urges
them
I can't say the word sin arrows siddi
the guidance provided in this book for
beef must be followed with great
responsibility never skip a step for
each victim of the protective returns a
sinner City the protector will be
rewarded with new levels tools and four
steps to follow step 1 a parasite the
possessor must locate the victims and
the parasite purchase parasite case more
go more go evaluate it if the victim is
in need of assistance if server the
Meseta said to the victim seems to have
forgotten his or her identity
the victim is already dead but just
realize it
I hope it's not that one I mean she
didn't have a reflection so the victim
believes the illusions of the beyond are
real the victim sympathizes with the
parasite
we might have all of those four because
she calls herself little misfortune she
doesn't call us up by a name and she
definitely sympathized and she does
believe that the illusions of real I
mean is that where her clitoris I don't
know
deforms reality into absurdity parasite
seems friendly yes it lowers the victim
to play dangerous games yeah it's
definitely more go it shape shifts into
a human animal creature it quickly
learns about the environment language
and culture and not an issue for this
parasite Oh large flocks of blackbirds
would appear near the parasite mother
Stephanie true these birds the eyes of
maka giving him an overview of his plane
ground using the surroundings to help
the victim become aware the parasite the
brook protects a cam for example wait
and paint simple messages and public
spaces to increase awareness it is
strictly forbidden to interact directly
okay so that's why he needs running
pastors it could lead to irreversible
former until the victims man
if the parasite kills the victim you
will need to proceed to step three
immediately
things I like to lend know in the woods
you will love or no direct contact with
the parasite
I guess well that's interesting quite a
bit there
this is also why I love what killed
Mundy games are so good at building up
like a whole or whole world with
different Browns and different
characters and just there's so much
backstory it's been so well thought out
these people are great
[Music]
and there's just the right amount of
relatability in the story and fantastic
porn us I was just so out of this world
you can relate to it but you really
can't
there's Benjamin did he leave that there
for her to find maybe I mean that is one
of his rules all right I guess I'll take
that dream back on you actually going
back home don't listen to that stupid
monster what are you doing
see he's leaving leaving all the nets
for us no one there when I look at this
I can see what Benjamin tried to warn me
about yeah Sasha folks a boy
okay oh it's here weigh them weigh them
but a little while oh okay I'm gonna
talk to myself Oh some is fortune how
have you been I think this is no good
this like weird as a monster
I saw those I saw Benjamin and then I
went to the suit and everything was
everywhere and then I realized mister
voice had lied to me a lot and he took
Benjamin and now I'm alone I don't like
being alone
Wow sounds like you had one hell of a
misfortune the train is here it was a
nice chat misfortune I'll talk to you
later he'll go girl
there he is
I'm very confused about who that boy is
they know much has been said about him
Oh cute what's this oh no I went over
the lines oh it's okay
okay
the next event an antenna I'm coloring
in
like dinosaurs
I'm great color let me just finish this
coloring book and then I will go next
oh look a little of her nap
happy inktober from the almost fortunes
a chunking asuras
beautiful
yes fabulous you did such a good job so
proud of you
great
how do I gonna hit an Australia Saurus
there's just so many different elements
to this game that like ready just bring
you in and get you a mast with being
almost watching like it brings you back
to just being that innocent kind of
playful kid again it's really sweet it's
really nice
paella koala I all laugh Authority
you look at this schedule butterfly
I did feel inspired chanting a sorcerer
pianist when people didn't recognize you
such a coincidence that you're on the
same train as me I mean he's a girl
singer where I had a big fight with the
silly voice in my hand but I don't think
it's a voice anymore I'm sure it's the
monster I saw it in a book have
Benjamin's place really Griffith how
many other heard voices in your head
I know Hina what does it mean
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna help here
[Music]
girlfriend maybe our friend was like one
of the lost kids like all taken to the
other realm and then he was coming back
to see if we're okay yeah I don't
I hope I get to stay here again my
mother
booster it to him I really have to walk
all the way back home alone this is the
last time I follow up voicing my head if
they knew me was here he will walk with
me
no he wouldn't cuz he's not allowed to
interact with you he's probably watching
you from somewhere there manga me was
warning me all that time but I couldn't
say it they wanted that eternal
happiness so bad
REO that's what I am
at least I had funneled phantasmagoria
yeah I mean tell mommy about it you
almost puked twice great times
oh no no I want to keep kicking it this
way I can't achievement for this okay
anyway
hey scary teens excuse me I'm talking
over here well if that's how you'll
trick a little like this then give
yourself up look she's so sassy I love
it
now look we're back home almost that
dad's crow is gone now daddy gone again
when I thought her dad wasn't around
anymore okay this isn't all - right we
got red lights hello no I feel like
you're in another round or maybe you are
dead
hello mommy bengi what happened here
congratulations you reached the end of
my game I'm looking for mommy a man
German there's no eternal happiness for
you I don't even care anymore of course
you can you know your mommy needs it
it's your responsibility yes because
you're right good good
ready for a new game if I play alone
will you give me back Benjamin I guess I
will but only if you truly commit to the
game splendid
you will love my new game
this is Miss Fortune she's a wonderful
child from a not so wonderful family for
you wait didn't I do this I'm ready no
no you're not doing this correctly then
you see something I don't mean dying
today which is totally natural by the
way wait stop talking please
are we going to put another game Horace
it's like what if you can reach the end
of the game I'll give you eternal
happiness and then you say deal and I
say yes stop ruining this wonderful
fantastic ready - wait what deal hmm how
about this what if the Fox wasn't
waiting for you in the hallway if the
game is about Benjamin you leaving me
alone I'll play along
sure sure I promise you know the way so
I wonder if his voice is changing
because he's like
slowly disappointing because she doesn't
she doesn't like it she's not down so
much she was in the beginning she come
to check over the carpet again you
promised you wouldn't be like last time
that was a beautiful example of cause
and effect you lied to me I don't want
to play this game anymore fine let me
come up with a new game to play new game
knock knock who's there knock-knock
who's
[Music]
Oh chica that's my band
oh he won't sign me in there no he knows
everything about open this door right
now
misfortune we have a new game to play I
told you already I don't want to play
with you anymore
constantly teach me how to be Brian
so now we're playing hide-and-seek I
love that game leave me alone all right
Justin so you know my game is the only
thing keeping you alive
is that one more of your lies we will
live forever with Menuhin and there's
nothing you can do about it will you
please stop talking about about Fox it's
been trying to take you away from me
all the time this turn of faith hands
yeah I'm not you don't talk like that
about my Benjamin yeah you know what
I'm done with you I want you to live
right now it's like this is not the last
game you play with me misfortune this is
only the beginning child another toy for
my collection
your mind to play with for eternity I'm
sick of you mean our bully will come
back and save me
no you made a deal you crossed the path
and now you're to the rescue
how did you get here there's nothing you
can do she belongs to me
go Benjamin guard
unmelted thought style Silver's
[Music]
not today Satan's of Dustin echos and I
agree
[Music]
now ah is everything back to normal
is everything back to normal Benjamin
saved me
Rangi are you around no he probably went
back to his place away I think he left
you something mojo is coming open your
eyes he is the voice in your head
driving you mad well it would have been
good to have had that in the beginning
but you know still thank you well no I
know what to call mister voice did you
go outside I guess I have to reveal this
I'll make some improvements but first I
want to find dangling I mean where are
you
where's my mom she back in the kitchen
oh there's a cigarette there so maybe oh
no I'm still not there look who do sit
on the side there mommy
there's a mom really frying a Mac
let me delete an army are you angry
because I couldn't get the happiness for
you right she done
I think she's man that dream how did she
die that
Oh
when he told us to be careful and to
look both ways and then she nearly got
hit I guess she actually did get hit at
the very beginning of the game
[Music]
Oh Bing eat your bank they thought I
lost you too
what's happening don't you go to the LM
race with him yeah the other realm
I mean you didn't even say goodbye to me
when I left the houses screw you mom
thank you wait are you taking me
somewhere else
because I am nothing against it but I
have to talk with my mommy first
I don't think you can talk to her
oh can you mommy I'm going to go
somewhere else with bengi okay she's the
folks that I like I'm gonna leave you
know that's what I am
wait Joe just said it's for dad's car
but you need to thing your oh my god was
that actually her dad's car that knocked
her over because I mean forever I don't
know but that's so sweet of her
[Music]
[Music]
so all the children are dead
they must be Luka
but the way thing is is that she was
dead and she was still seeing her
quote/unquote dead friend so what is
that all about
unless he was her ally friend wait stop
Benjamin what are we going thank you
I love this little mouse identity killed
by killed it after I was dead so I'm
confused everything I did after crossing
that Burroughs technically dead
okay we're crossing Browns now
oh nothing weird caterpillar
creepy
hey I remember those some Fran bow a
little walking a corny things they were
in Franco - wait what is its name I
forgot ah someone remind me please don't
let me what was his name from Fran bow
aha see they're coming together it's in
the same like universe it's so cool uh
what was his name that's gonna bug me
now
[Music]
oh this place is really cool
what's he caught mister semester I can
Laura's name was Edward thank you
Michael
it would yes it would
[Music]
all around disasters seems to disappear
deep inside the fog around disasters
seem to disappear deep inside the book
you defeat him that's doing my good
mister voice game is over now thank you
I'm glad the game isn't finished I was I
was I thought it might finish it's been
too short
who are you Merlin Elena misfortune
that's who I am
lady misfortune yes you could say that
good stuff inside we were expecting yeah
one
what is this place
no no I can't see me oh it's just saying
oh I thought it might be the end nodes
get inside no I don't wanted to be over
um I knew that was Natalia's boys who is
doing misfortune yeah it's brilliant
voice acting she's she was perfect she
was spot-on and yeah she sounded so
freaking cute and if I don't watches
kill Mondays YouTube videos like they're
just so likable there doesn't really
like have a bunch of people yeah this
game was amazing the art style has
stepped up so much since fram bro and
Fran bow looked great too
so that's a massive compliment just the
the way that they're able to build up a
character that's so unique so relatable
yet so freaking out there and crazy is
admirable I love her capacity for liking
imagination and well building how well
building is crazy it's just it's just so
nice to play a game
has created his own logic
I don't know yeah it's just really
really cool they've just sort of pretty
much everything and I can't wait to see
their next game I know they're making
and other Rambo guys so that'll be
interesting and who knows maybe friend
Bo wall me little misfortune it'll be
kind of like a mix mash of both games
together obviously I don't know I'm just
just chat try and stuff but that would
breed alcohol if that does happen
anyway I was extremely impressed by this
game they have come so very far and I
know they don't have the biggest team so
it's just pretty cool to see and it's
really nice that they document that
process behind developing the game as
well do check out their YouTube channel
it's pretty cool
I've told you guys a thousand times but
yeah I really like killed Monday games
they they cool they cool guys think good
good guys
anyway what did you guys think of the
game you let me know in the comments
below I'll we upload this one I'll
probably just cut it a little bit but
yeah really for anyone who didn't get a
chance to see it if you want to see the
beginning of the game it is all uploaded
on my channel so go back along you can
find the last one and there is a whole
playthrough of me playing front bone
which is just as good as this game it's
darker and creepier though just a
warning but yeah a lot of hype for the
next game matters yeah but not just a
hope for the next game just yeah a lot
of gratitude for this game I know how
much time and effort must have gone into
it it's not easy making a game and all
that hard work and effort paid off
because it is truly unique very
entertaining and
rememberable memorable rememberable what
is a remember remember all memorable so
yeah very very good job much enjoyed it
looks like you guys really liked it as
well music in the game so relaxing could
listen to it all day it's relaxing but
also I like that I had kind of a rock
vibes as well look we got no extras
what's the edges oh okay so it's like
the dolls that we got and the cinematics
gallery I like that they're kind of
animations to you oh that's cool
phantasmagoria was an awesome place Oh
Northern Lights Benji oh look she does
have a reflection although I did call it
I did say that maybe she was dead she
didn't have a reflection cute okay
anyway I'm gonna say goodbye to who I
can see now thank you very much for
watching as I said before let me know in
the comments what you thought of this
video game this video game this game and
yeah have a lovely day or evening
good bye montage good bye Luca good bye
chimera goodbye Nikki give a joke pike
good bye so Benji be good bye